hello and welcome to the plate well last
weekend Chelsea's goalkeeper and manager
had a pretty public bust up Mira - sorry
wanted a substitute pepper in the League
Cup final but the Spaniard aflutter
refused after an extraordinary couple of
minutes a furious finger wagging and
shouting the manager caved in of a girl
who stayed on now we on the pledge can
sympathize with poor mr. sorry
last summer I tried to kick Greg off the
paddle but he just refused to leave that
chair and over six months later and he
still hasn't budged just fine divas on
the football coming up on the show
Nick argues we're getting mixed messages
Michelle puts her hand up for updated
sex it Travie thinks footballers need
taking down a pic and Greg doesn't want
to give up control but first it's me
this week Jeremy Corbyn committed the
greatest brexit betrayal of all by
agreeing to support a peoples vent he
stuck two fingers up at the working
class as millions of whom have already
voted to leave and he became a knight in
shining armor for a bunch of elitist
middle class remainders he has betrayed
those voters in Labour's harland's
remember more than 60% of labour
constituencies voted leave in order to
save his own political skin and to hold
the exodus of MPs from his party no
sooner had this life long you were
skeptic Scheldt his principles for
political expediency Theresa May
announced that she will ditch her
promises and let mp's vote to delay
brexit next month which they will as
Parliament is stuffed full of remainders
so I'm having vowed to the British
people that we will leave on March the
29th our gutless p.m. has buckled under
pressure from her own ministers what's
now clear is that the entire political
establishment is working against British
people to thwart brexit and for that
they will pay the price
[Music]
the things it seems to me Carol is that
you're picking on the poor kid on the
edge of the playground who frankly isn't
in the fight the Labour Party is in a
pathetic state it's in a row about
anti-semitism the magic Grand Park
Corbin has turned into sad uncle Jeremy
and he's sort of present but not
involved I'm wondering why today you
aren't having the people who are the
European I speak so you've just accused
me a lot of things you said he's not the
person vault he is just a person who was
agreed to support people's vote the man
who for the last two years has said he
would not support a people so and when
you say I'm picking on the kid in the
playground who was not responsible this
man is in charge of a party who has just
betrayed 70% of the people who vote for
it
he had the working-class voters who
voted for brexit have been betrayed not
only has these that not only have these
people being betrayed but democracy has
been betrayed and Jeremy Corbyn has
helped that happen yeah but let's
remember that most labour voters also
voted remained let me just come in on
that and give you some actual figures in
the 270 2017 election 8 million remained
voters voted labour in the 2017 general
election for millions leave voters voted
Labour's in other words twice as many
were their main voters and in the 2016 a
new referendum labour voters split 67
percent voting remain 33 percent voted
leave okay so your figures are actually
wrong seventy percent of labour
constituencies voted to the no use
anyway the people in Labour's heartlands
which have now been researched 70
percent of labour voters they didn't
right 70 percent let's make it as clear
70 percent of labour constituencies most
of which are in Babers hardness the
truth those people have that's because
the Tories all voted
the viewers you're losing the view stop
with the percentages please don't
understand let me just say this I just
make one off point my point Carol is not
you know I have a great esteem for
Jeremy Corbyn I mean I'm public on this
my point is they're irrelevant at the
moment the people who are calling the
shots here are inside the Conservative
Party why aren't we talking about them
because what Karen has floated is where
the labor position is and let's let's
not worry about percentages we did have
a vote nearly three years ago there was
a result and after that the Labour Party
went to the public and said labour will
support the result of the referendum and
that's that much and that's what they
have failed to do and I think mr. Corbyn
and I sense I know why he's doing it
I think if he hadn't had done that he
might have lost some more MPs remember
he's lost a number already so he's got
hemorrhaging MPs I think that's why he's
done it but I actually although not use
your level of language I do think
there's an insult to you
let me just let me read out this thing
this is about this is the manifestos of
both parties before the last election so
this takes in you all say that the
Tories are to blame labour 2017 election
manifesto quote labour accepts the
referendum result and a Labour
government will put the national
interest first conservators 2017
election manifesto following the
historic referendum on June the 23rd
2016 the United Kingdom is leaving the
European Union those parties the Tories
got in on the back of that promise and
82 percent of voters back to these two
parties on permanent day so they have
let the voters down I feel let down by
leav ads or all of them quite frankly
and I don't know if you saw what Owen
Smith was saying I think it's a couple
of days ago when he was talking about
brexit being a racist and a phobic
project which I thought was so insulting
I really did find insourcing caps and I
feel like their will that while they are
disconnecting with a huge number of
their base who want brixey who wanted
brexit and still want brexit and I also
feel the people that defaulted from laya
bars are going to take I think it's
absolutely shameful that they got
elected on the back of a Labour
manifesto and haven't been forced to
have a by-election I've done that
absolutely
terrible yeah tickets the independent
group just say we spin out that's the
history of people crossing them people
change it no people changing the old
crossing the house virtually never
resign but that doesn't mean sits right
yeah if you get elected on the back of
it and I understand the technicalities
that you're voting for an individual I
understand how it style but also many
people are voting for parties and
manifesto promises and if you default
from that which I think you're
absolutely entitle to do you there
should be a change in law that a
by-election is automatically triggered
and I think it's shameful that it's not
when you have mp's labor impose like
David Lammy saying almost every other
day
let's end this nightmare of bricks that
what are you saying is let's in
democracy no let's end and listen let me
just finish the point let's end the
right of ordinary people to have a say
in the future the ring knows that's why
I think the argument is is quite strong
but I don't think about happen for
another vote and the other boat would
say look we now know what we're voting
for we've got three choices there's mrs.
Mays deal No Deal and leave and or we
will remain let's what's wrong with
asking people against democracy well I
tell you what the problem with that is
Gregg you have three options on your
ballot paper there is no way any of
those action options will attract
seventeen point four million votes so
you will end up you would end up with
another referendum which is won by a
group which is smaller than the group of
one I just wonder whether we're getting
sucked into the parliamentary
imagination I know that the MPs are
having a fantastic time here I mean
there are people here who are straight
whose names aren't even known to their
neighbors who are on telly every day and
they're having a fantastic time but
shouldn't we really be thinking about
how do we get a deal and then get on
with doing some of the things that
really matter don't you think the music
mrs. mains deal now actually when he
comes back with some words that help to
overcome the Irish problem I think
there's good chance a conservative party
chairman said he thinks they're going to
offer a little bit more which is you may
well be right it is explore let's move
it forward a little bit because you also
said something that you think
politicians will face a tremendous
backlash isn't it
you think the Anasuya is in the
hi Gianna bugs are looking I think
nobody's gonna vote for them I think I
think the people who've currently vote
Labour I think will turn to you Kip and
I think they will leave as yes yeah but
it'll come back and fire always one day
the brexit party yes and you yes exactly
maybe what we ought to do here what
Labor says for itself John McDonnell set
out why they have made this switch we
were clear in our manifesto we want to
respect the last referendum but we've
now been pushed to the edge by the Prime
Minister we say she's running down the
clock and it's getting dangerous now
she's about directly econo if we're not
careful so we're forced into a position
whereby exactly as we said the
referendum we've got to block a No Deal
we've got to block a reckless deal as
well so the only way we're left now the
only way were left is going back to the
people well you know I've got some
simply through what you're saying
careless but you know you're a bit
extravagant about this the point is the
Labour Party clearly has nothing very
much to say all it's saying is let's
have another vote they're not telling us
about what you just said there and his
party has just voted let's not get too
hung up on the the important thing is
how do we fulfil that promise
that's really what the issues and I
think Greg is right that actually where
we may end up with is something a bit
like the reason Mays deal and I think
most of the country basically is fed up
gives this sort of us what we're I think
what Carol saying is important is that
what we may be seeing is the collapse of
the current political architecture and
from my point of view good think the
collapse of the Labour Party for
absolutely oh don't kid yourself this is
only a party of the people and they have
just ignored the wishes of their people
by we've gone through those numbers
that's not true they didn't they're in a
very difficult position because a third
of their voters voted out right so a
third of them voted out so that gives
them a border with a border we must move
on